I was watching this documentary last
night and it had me thinking about maybe
your situation and that is these
filmmakers had been accepted into this
prestigious program and they thought
they just try it and when they got the
letter they almost felt like someone was
playing a joke on them that they got in
yeah absolutely did was that and then
when we were talking off-camera that
that sparked this quite so was that
something that when you applied to leave
you said Hendrix yeah yeah so so
basically I applied the film school kind
of as a built-in excuse to not pursue my
dreams if that makes sense so I was just
like I'm gonna apply to I'm gonna apply
to USC film school and no one gets into
there so I'm gonna apply get rejected
and then I can say I tried and then I
can go about my life and I was gonna
work it like a like a gas company in
Arkansas like that was that's what I was
gonna do after graduation and I ended up
actually not doing that and I worked as
a youth director for a little while but
so I applied to USC in the middle of
planning my wedding
basically oh wow and I got a response
one one day like literally an email that
said like the subject line was like RSVP
for admitted students day because I
guess they sent the email in the wrong
order
and I was like admitted students say
what does that mean and then a few
minutes later I got like admission
decision thing so I found out kind of in
Reverse and I was so confused and I did
I thought someone played a joke on me
and I and I found out I got I got into
USC about two weeks before I was gonna
get married and so I was so stunned and
I was talking my wife and I was like so
like I'm not gonna go and she's like no
no you have to go and my wife was in the
middle of pharmacy school at the time so
she couldn't just pick up and leave what
she was doing so that meant like she she
pushed me to say yes to pursue my dreams
and so we got married and then literally
two weeks later after we got me
I moved to Los Angeles to start film
school it was pretty wild
yeah but it was amazing because like
it's just a testament to how awesome my
wife is like yeah if she hadn't have
pushed me to say yes to go pursue your
dreams I probably wouldn't have done it
I probably wouldn't have it didn't how
long before she joined you here so we
were apart for two years so for the
first two years of film school I I was
just out here by myself in a
long-distance marriage which was pretty
pretty wild but it would but it worked
out great Wow that I think that'd be
tough for a lot of people to be
separated for a long time like that and
plus you had you been to Los Angeles
before no no I had never never been to
California at all so it was like one of
those like almost fish-out-of-water
experiences like I got here and I
remember one of the first things was
just showing up at LAX it's just scary
is scary it's terrifying you're like
wait whoa this one terminal is the size
of my entire Airport where I'm from you
know right and so and you know the cars
circle and you have circling its called
panic attacks or yeah exactly exactly
and like I
I like stepped out of the airport and
suddenly I was like it felt like I was
on a completely new planet you know and
then then what was weird is that I
remember her when I got to school like I
was the crosswalks in in general like I
remember the crosswalks counted down
from 30 and back where I'm home they
count down from 10 and I was like what
is this like it's not take me 30 seconds
to get across the street and in a lot of
places it does so it was just like very
strange and I remember the first time I
I parked my car in the parking deck at
USC I didn't have that skill where
you're like okay let me remember what
row I'm on you know and I I just parked
my car and I went to class and when I
came back I couldn't find my car and me
and my friend spent like four hours in
the parking deck looking for my car and
this is like a you know an eight story
parking I've been there
Dec I had no idea where my car was I was
like one of my first experiences out
here and people drive pretty fast too
and that yeah you can die yeah yeah well
the second part of that question goes to
the fact that these same people that
were accepted that thought someone was
playing a joke on them that they got in
then they were in this setting where
they were getting peer feedback mm-hmm
and they had never been through a
process like that before and it was
actually quite upsetting to them totally
yeah kind of broke people some of them
they absolutely I was just wandering
without maybe you could just talk in
general terms but how that was to get
feedback yeah it's a it's a weird
experience so you know and I and I say
this all with love and stuff for USC cuz
it's it's it's my oh my I love it I love
it with all my heart but the the
feedback process especially in film
school is like unnerving in so many ways
because it's almost like tearing down
people's work is almost like sport
they're like it's like oh yeah you think
you're good we'll check this out and you
know and and at the end of the day it's
all out of love even though it's like
really hard harsh love it's all to make
the work better but I mean coming from
me I'd never really experienced that
before and I remember the first time we
played my my dailies there was a room of
like 50 people in it and I never forget
this this this one but the first comment
that I got somebody raised their hand
and said it doesn't look like this movie
was directed by anybody and I was like
oh yeah oh that's what I'm in for
and and the funny part was like they
were kind of right because like I I you
just couldn't tell any intention in my
work at the time you know but like that
was like the tone of of how rough the
notes process would be moving forward
throughout school and but at the what's
what's weird is like after that class I
actually went and I cried in the in the
courtyard I I went and I was like I'll
be right back guys and I went and I wept
and I wept bitterly and I had a moment
after I wept and I realize oh I'm still
here I'm still here I can try again and
it seems like that process sort of it
sharpened me if you will and now I love
people's feedback on my work I love it
and now when people and I've had this
I've had with my with my first feature
I've had people literally walk up to me
and say this is the worst know you've
ever seen I'm like okay that's fine and
it doesn't really bother me anymore cuz
like I know my work ethic I know my
intentions as a director I know what I'm
trying to do so it it helped me in the
long run and now actually I love it
because I think the notes process the
feedback process only sharpens your work
and makes it better if you know what
your intention behind the work is so I
love it now
you